arrived at paris's criminal court with
his co-accused a judge frowned Bowie and
two other men guilty of plotting to kill
the French President a fourth man was
convicted of having a weapon they were
handed sentences of six months to three
years Boyer's lawyer said the
accusations had been exaggerated
I had hoped for magistrates who would
have the intellectual honesty to
acknowledge that this case isn't what it
should have been and was blown out of
proportion
a former mechanic drew the attention of
French police by his posts on social
media French intelligence put him under
surveillance in 2018 after a tip-off
that a far-right militant was planning
to attack Emmanuel macron in a first
world war commemoration Bowie had
described macro online as a hysterical
dictator he'd like to wipe out he was
arrested along with three others a
commando-style knife and an army vest
were found in his car all were said to
be members of a secretive far-right
Nationalist and anti-immigration group
known as the belgol movement their
arrests were made during widespread
public descent which culminated with
demonstrations by the anti-government
yellowfests movement
there is more hatred of President macron
far more than a president Sarkozy in
Holland we saw it during the crisis
involving the yellow vest protesters and
that is something to take into account
without having any sympathy for
ultra-right terrorists there are groups
of people who are becoming radicalized
another nine people had also faced trial
and connection with the case but the
judge acquitted them
during the trial defense lawyers said
that their clients were ordinary
citizens who vented their anger with
President macron mainly online proposed
no real danger prosecutors however
argued that the threats of violence were
very real Natasha Butler Al Jazeera
Paris